our guest today is someone who holds a
very special place in my life and
we actually hadn't spoken in almost 20
years and then
we regrouped and came back into each
other's lives he
did us the awesome privilege of coming
on the show
a couple months weeks ago i'm a pisces i
have no timeline
conception uh concept and he's an actor
one of the most groundbreaking comedians
in the world
in history in my opinion and he's an
all-around kind soul
and right now he comes to us live from
his van
in the desert it's tom green
wow i drew what an intro
thank you so much good to see you hello
oh tom
and charlie yeah charlie's here too
tommy yes you look cool i'm i'm living
in my van down by the river drew um
things are going good no i uh i'm having
a great time actually i'm
i'm new mexico and i'm traveling across
the country and uh
doing a lot of uh filming and uh uh
and uh my podcast and i'm having fun but
it was so much fun like you said it was
it's been fun reconnecting with you and
um you're pretty good at scrabble
oh so we're playing a mean game of
scrabble
uh it's actually my turn but my letters
suck
so badly look at this board a i i i
a a v i
i'm determined not to swap them out we
our last game was
really good i didn't take a screenshot
of that board
but um where it's so much fun to play
scrabble go with you
yes absolutely it's been it's been cool
you know i i uh
i'm often in places where i have no cell
reception in fact i had to drive into
the small town of aztec uh new mexico
just to do this call so i'm uh but uh
because it's
i've been going to these really remote
places i've been going out to uh
uh this incredible place called valley
of the gauze utah there you're looking
at it right there now
and uh i i find these spots that i just
think photograph well
and i have this little drone that i take
these pictures with
and i fly the drone up and get these
amazing shots and it's a lot of fun but
often you have no cell service which is
actually kind of nice because
you know we're so connected now on their
phones
to be able to go spend four or five days
not being able to talk to anybody is
actually kind of nice sometimes
i've got larry and charlie too so things
are good i mean
what i mean like you're traveling around
you'll go and do like the joe rogan show
and you'll do drone shots and you'll
share videos and you're so technically
inclined
but what is it like on the reels to just
drop out like i turn my cell phone off
for
weeks and months at a time but i'm still
so engrossed in life and people i mean
first of all i have kids so i'm you know
it's
it's like i'm always with them but being
with them doesn't feel like i'm tuned
into society it's like a whole separate
spiritual like
life i've plugged into with them what is
it
giving you what's it like because people
don't do this
and there's something we all don't know
because we're not committing to this
like you
you know i've spent a lot of time
traveling in the last decade
you know doing stand-up and that all
stopped with
kovid and uh you know after spending
about
six months sitting around my house you
know twiddling my thumbs and
wondering when this thing was gonna end
i said you know i just i wanna
i wanna i wanna do something uh uh
and i i decided to kind of throw myself
into
some projects and things that i've
always wanted to do and not had time to
do like photography like these are some
photos i shot
um and uh and and then the the
filmmaking and editing and
it's very technical with the cameras and
all the and the editing and all that so
you really have to put
some time into that i love these photos
you're the one who bought me my pentax
k-1000 camera
oh yeah oh my god 20 years ago and
and i you know i tom i have to show you
all the
professional work i did like i shot
covers of magazines and campaigns and
it's all because of you i didn't i've
seen some of them i've seen some of them
yeah i have a whole book like i put
together
like i was taking it to agents like i
thought that's where my life was gonna
go
before this show started i was gonna
become like an interior designer or a
photographer and
you know all these other things and i
think what you're doing and what's
important
is that we do explore these passions of
ours and we don't let
life go by with this sort of
diligent horse blinders of there is only
one way we only have one mission
one job one group one place of geography
we have to make the most of this time on
this planet and explore the things
that we want to literally explore
yeah exactly and so and and i i think
your question was how do you handle
being alone too you know i'm
alone in this van with larry and charlie
who have an interesting relationship
these two also by the way
but uh you know no i mean larry's being
a little quiet right now but i'll tell
you you can really get going
but um uh you know i've sort of
filled my life in this van right now
with things to do so i'm taking the
pictures and traveling and then you know
where we
you do get connected with people on the
on on online and stuff as well and i
talk to my friends and i go home to los
angeles occasionally too i think i will
go back to my house someday but i'm
having too much fun on the road right
now so
well i think you are oh yeah sorry go
ahead i want to tell you this drew too
because it gets cold at night
in the van okay i'm in new mexico now
it's snowed today
i'm canadian so i can handle it but what
you need if you ever decide to go out
in a van okay drew which i which i i can
see this in your future
moving in an rv around america like
most of my life i can see next time if
you don't know what these are
okay these are called down booties
okay down booties okay
and uh you put those on your feet at
night and you get into your sleeping bag
and it's also and it's just a
life-changing thing so this is this is
something that makes me happy right now
drew
down booty send me a picture of them
with the brand and i'll put it on the
little yellow book list
and oh yeah thank you and will you check
back in with us
like really soon because we're having so
much fun
and i think that just to have this
peaceful quiet reminder
is really important and then let's check
back in
absolutely i i would love to yeah for
sure we'll keep playing scrabble i i'm
down one game so uh
rematch and yeah people can follow along
with what i'm doing just go look at my
youtube channel and
uh and there's lots of cool little films
and stuff on there that i'm doing and
i'm having a good time thank you drew
it's so great to be here congratulations
on the show
going so well you're hilarious on the
show by the way i've told you this uh
you know but i i've been like you know
again i'm in the desert but then i'll
come into cell service and i'll see on
your instagram
you know these hilarious things you're
doing which to me i just think is like
what daytime television needs it needs a
little more
like wackiness i i said on the joe rogan
show i think you're being real
wacky right i i i like i like wackiness
you know i'm a bit of a wacky guy myself
but like uh you know like the the the
different screams
like i was just i was i've had i've had
a lot of laughs uh watching uh your
clips on social media while i'm out here
in the band so congratulations i'm proud
of you and uh
i'm so happy for you and if you think
it's funny
i'm happy because you are a pioneer of
funny
genre that did not exist before you so
everybody
check out tom's stuff it'll be all over
our website
i'll see you in a minute on scrabble go
you